[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue alors qui sort gagnant
qui sort perdant des discussions autour
des accords pas d'accord entre eux l air
et les rues m
en paca refaire les comptes ce soir avec
philippe meyer bonsoir philippe le
philippe meyer ça c'est l'adresse de
philippe sur twitter
créateur et animateur du nouvel esprit
public l'esprit public tout attachés
sans apostrophe point fr à la fin 100%
podcast 100% web dernier numéro en date
est en ligne consacré à l'insécurité aux
violences urbaines et à la fin de la
guerre en afghanistan c'est très
intéressant et donc il faut aller sur le
web pour aller l'écouter et avec nous
avec vous ce soir alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du groupe
figaro bonsoir allégorie soir on va
revenir longuement également dans le
dans le figaro dans les prochaines
heures sur les commémorations autour de
naples et rabat napoléon bien sûr genre
demain et les cérémonies seront
également à suivre en direct sur figaro
là il va leur en est
en attendant une question quel hommage
rendre à napoléon on en reparle dans une
dizaine de minutes après avoir fait un
petit exercice d'exégèse politique car
car le communiqué de renaud muselier est
tombée en milieu d'après-midi alors ils
n'étaient pas guetter autant qu'une
fumée blanche à la sortie d'un conclave
mais enfin il a quand même fait parler
avant qu'il n'arrive et voici ce qu'on
peut lire il n'y aura pas d'accord à
quelques niveaux que ce soit avec en
marche pas plus qu'avec d'autres
appareils voilà donc ce que promet ce
soir renaud muselier dans ce communiqué
mais mais je suis sensible à tous les
soutiens qui se manifeste le premier
ministre m'a apporté son soutien c'est
la reconnaissance éminente de la qualité
de notre bilan et de notre travail c'est
aussi une réponse à la volonté
d'ouverture que j'ai à plusieurs
reprises exprimé sur twitter
notre confrère de lci renaud pila écrit
si vous ne comprenez rien aux
communiqués de renaud muselier c'est
mission accomplie
il fallait que chacun sauver son honneur
est ce que c'est votre lecture et quelle
est votre lecture alexis
oulala c'est autrefois il y avait les
kremlinologues heure là il y aller il
faut être
je veux dire pas ko log pour comprendre
quelque chose d'histoire auxquels
personne n'entend rien ces officiers de
la résumer mais je voudrais pas perdre
le téléspectateur en cours de route
en gros muselier craignant de perdre
face au front national en paca s'allie
avec ce fils comment s'appelle-t-elle
sophie cluzel qui est le père craignait
elle en marche qui craignait de ne pas
être au second tour parce que c'était ça
qui lui pendait au nez c'est déjà là des
faibles tous les deux si on salit ça
veut faire plus au front national face
au front national là dessus tout que le
premier ministre annonce à grand son de
trompe comme la halle et le début les
bauges le loup l'acte fondateur d'une
immense rue position politique qui
trouve son plein accomplissement la
présidentielle bruno le maire à audi
darmana dit c'est formidable l'ailer
disait amusé des militantes est en train
de nous trahir
qu'est ce que c'est que ces histoires
que tu me fais dans doit-on ça va pas se
passer comme ça on va te retirer nos
captures de fer nice contre toi musique
et prend peur commence par dire non non
non mais d'ailleurs sophie cluzel
viendra pas sur ma liste c'était une
fusion si la fusion le gars qui fusionne
vient pas sa liste c'est un problème
non non on reviendra pas sur ben ali
s'est dit non mais ça suffit pas tu vas
maintenant dire qu'il ya pas de
recomposition nationale tu vas dire que
tu que jamais ce que cela ne préfigure
quelque chose pour macron et tu vas te
le dire il va il ya ce matin une réunion
au sommet et alors là mais je sors et
dit je suis un homme libre et je vous
dirai à l'issue de ces dans l'après midi
ce que j'ai décidé il dit tout ce que
lui a demandé de dire se dire qu'il n'y
aura pas d'alliance qu'il n'y a plus
d'alliance que c'est fini et est bon en
fait en gros on revient à la case départ
et je me tourne les j'en ai fini là
dessus je pense qu'on a nous manque le
dernier épisode qui n'est pas certain
mais qui me paraît pas impossible
c'est que la liste en marche reviennent
parce que tous ces braves gens qui
s'étaient présentés sur l'histoire
marche il n'était pas sûr de faire 10%
m'en faisais quelque chose allait se
présenter quand même une élection c'est
peut-être quelque chose de prévu mais
ils sont plus du tout sur les listes de
qui vous dirait bien puisque c'est comme
ça on recommence tout ce qu'on aura fait
tout ce cinéma tout ce cirque pour
revenir à la case départ au motif au
prétexte de combattre le front national
est à mon avis le seul vainqueur de tout
ça de ce spectacle auto rigole mais
quand même navrant c'est le front
national
vous me demandiez tout à l'heure
philippe 6
muselier elles étaient exclus ou pas je
vous propose d'écouter à la réponse de
christian jacob et vous ferait sens
l'exégèse christian jacob n'est pas du
tout dans un sujet d'exclusion on est
dans un sujet qui est simple il y a dans
cette région un très bon bilan de la
majorité régionale qu'est la majorité
régionale
les républicains c'est ça qui est
important il y a aujourd'hui
effectivement une manoeuvre politicienne
dans marche parce que encore une fois
ils font le constat d'échec de ne pas
pouvoir conduire une liste et donc ils
sont allés petite manoeuvre
bon ben il faut il faut savoir les
éviter et rebondir sur nos bases
donc ce soir c'est apparemment ce qui
s'est passé sont toujours petite console
10 ensuite le communiqué de monsieur
muselier m'a rappelé une blague qu'on
faisait quand j'étais collégien qui dit
plus une deux chevaux va moins vite
moins et les plus durs a dépassé et
enfin je pense qu'au bal des cocus qui
va manquer musiciens alors qu'istres
parce que en effet muselier comme vient
de le dire alexis est allé à canossa
et en homme libre fait ce qu'on lui
demandait
le premier ministre a plus l'air d'un
que d'un moulin à vent est effectivement
alexis le prédit je crois juste titre la
liste de marc cluzel va de voir renaître
ce qui d'ailleurs entre parenthèses ce
qui vient de se passer peut peut-être
lui apporter à cette liste nam cluzel un
peu plus de suffrages kelly pas parce
que du coup des gens qui étaient poussés
à voter pour muselier devant cette
absence du courage pour utiliser une
litote vont peut-être se dire que comme
ils ne veulent pas voter à l'extrême
droite ils peuvent j'en sais rien mais
c'est pas à linverse et plein de gens
qui étaient tentés au départ de voter
avec madame cluzel voyant qu'elle était
prête à s'allier avec muselier pour ces
gens et tous ces gens qui pour beaucoup
ne sont pas de droits du tout ne
viennent pas de relater vient du taux de
la gauche une gauche certes modéré d'une
gauche quand même vous dire non mais à
terme c'est fini on quitte cluzel et on
va donc vers la vraie gauche car il
voyait aussi avoir une liste devrait il
va y avoir plusieurs mais peut-être une
oui il y en a qu'une elle peut faire un
disque c'est pas impossible c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'en effet il y aura plus
de danseurs et de musiciens au bal des
cocus et aussi je pense que il ya un
cocu reporter suspect durant cocuage
reporter c'est celui de monsieur mariani
parce que pour le moment ça va mais on a
bien vu et notamment la semaine dernière
que ses rapports avec le front national
fait du rassemblement national était
gravement endommagé par cette espèce de
gouvernance extrêmement ferme et
dictatoriale des pieds nickelés d'hénin
beaumont le maire d'hénin le maire de
fréjus puis un troisième
bien que j'oublie et que au fond ça met
en lumière une chance marine le pen non
des trois ayant la 3 particulièrement
qui sont occupés de distribuer de donner
que de virer un nombre cancer je crois
qu'il ya pratiquement 80 des 100 d'eads
a essayé restituer aux eyrieux de du
rassemblement national sortant qui sont
priés de rentrer chez eux sans qu'on
puisse dire s'ils ont démérité ou
quelles sont les raisons de ce retrait
brutal et qui à la place ont mis leur
jean marc mariani s'est battu il a
claqué la porte il a obtenu d'avoir un
certain nombre de gens bon c'est pas
d'ailleurs déposé à la liste c'est le 18
mai on pourra donc il ya encore des
bagarres de deux couloirs et des
couteaux qui peuvent sortir dans les
couloirs de diverses manières
mais l'une des choses à mon avis que
démontrera l'existence de mariani si
jamais il fait un bon score peut-être
même s'il gagne cette élection c'est que
très vite à l'intérieur du front
national on verra cas parce qu'il faut
pour gouverner ils n'ont pas les hommes
ils n'ont pas les hommes on l'a dit de
maquereaux à juste titre qu'il était
entouré au point de vue parlementaires
que des gens qu'il avait choisi et qui
ne qui devait tout à lui que du coup le
parlement n'existait pas et c
mais le front national c'est mille fois
pire c'est mille fois pire ya un petit
état major des gens qui sont autour de
marine le pen dans un état de siège
permanent sans même que sans être
attaqué il organise la défense contre un
siège et dans l'année qui vient à mon
avis une des choses qui sautera aux yeux
c'est l'incapacité l'impréparation grâce
à dieu mort ce qui me concerne du
rassemblement national à gouverner avant
de revenir d'être sur le
les possibilités et les capacités
éventuelle de gouvernance du
rassemblement national pour venir à
muselier donc flip disait il a manqué de
courage ce soir mais ce qu'il a manqué
d'intelligence finalement en reculant
alexis moi je dirais surtout qu'il a
manqué de courage au début de l'histoire
en tombant dans ce piège énorme qui est
déçu ce qui lui a été tendue notamment
pour estrosi et puis par thierry solère
qui était de dire fauceille litois avec
macron ça va être super tu vas être élu
puis tu vas voir les autres ils vont
rien dire d'abord c'était très bête de
penser que les républicains allaient se
laisser faire sans rien dire il n'y en
hiver faire une liste contre toi et
toute façon votre faire battre et par
ailleurs je pense que ce que
arithmétiquement ils avaient tort
c'est sur ça que je ne comprends pas la
dernière fois aux dernières régionales
eux
marion maréchal-le pen fait 40% au
premier tour et en dépit de salle ne
gagne pas le second tour la marianne y
feront leurs ascendants nationale et
musulmans est grosso modo aux mêmes
niveaux à 30 33 % s'étaient pas 40 donc
à 30%
ça se joue et si il faut s'allier avec
les en marche
on s'est dit entre les deux tours à quoi
bon faire autant une alliance entre les
deux tours ça fait mauvais effet il ya
des gens qui crient mutation ça va très
vite et puis si on gagne tout est
pardonné et si on perd on parle plus de
vous donc dans 2 des cas mais c'est là
on voit bien qu'entre les deux tours
l'idc il faut gagner on fait ce qu'il
faut pour gagner mais n'a lens avant le
premier tour c'est pas ça et bien sûr le
tour c'est un signal politique ça veut
dire on est plus qu'un seul parti on
fait partie de la même famille pour
l'avenir et c'est très exactement le
plan de macron c'est de dire il ya
aujourd'hui plus que et c'est aussi
d'ailleurs le plan de marine le pen qui
l'un et l'autre pense que la politique
française se restructurer autour de deux
grands pôles un pôle front national
élargi à une partie de la droite la plus
adroite et un grand pôle macro nist
équivaudrait tous vivre autour de ça il
se trouve qu'au milieu il ya les
républicains qui passe ne sont pas
absolument désireux de disparaître et
qui là bas ont tenu bon et je pense que
s'il s'y muselier avait tenu bon
il avait je dis pas qu'il avait
l'assurance de gagner la région paca
mais je pense que ils avaient plus de
chances de gagner la région paca ya
trois jours avance toute cette histoire
qu'aujourd'hui tous qui leurs méfaits de
rien dire de mener sa campagne ce que va
faire par an vous allez bertrand
nord et qu'est ce qui fait que guy
bertrand dit moi je mène ma campagne je
je ferait jeu égal avec le front
national au second tour il ya des il y
aura des recours naturel les marcheurs
pourront pas se maintenir donc il
faudrait bien qui vote pour quelqu'un
ils voteront pour moi j'aurais pas
besoin de m'allier avec eux et je
gagnerai ça marche ou ça marche pas mais
ça ne mérite d'être clair et si ça
marche on a vraiment gagné quelque chose
mais se vendre pour un plat de lentilles
avant même d'avoir mené bataille
ça me paraît c'est le signe qu'on a
perdu ses nerfs
c'est une faute politique ils ont ils
ont tenu bon 10 alexis a proposé des
républicains est ce que d'après vous
philippe la droite de la droite et en
particulier l'air peut échapper un terme
à l' explosion entre deux tendances
entre drogue de droite irréconciliables
à côté on voit quand même que
l'intérieur est miné alors quand ça
tombe vite lentement j'en sais rien mais
de l'intérieur sabine et c'est d'autant
plus miné que ceux qui ont les épaules
pour être des candidats de rassemblement
d'une bonne partie de l'air soient n'y
vont pas comme barrois soit 10 que
peut-être il pourrait y aller mais qui
n'y vont pas mais qui pourrait peut-être
y aller mais qui n'y vont pas comme
barnier soit ont fichu le camp pour
faire campagne sur leur propre drapeau
comme xavier bertrand pour le cette
histoire de pas qu'à moi j'ai la
faiblesse de croire quand même que l'on
vote aussi pour des gens pour un homme
pour une tête de liste dans cette
affaire monsieur muselier qui a d'abord
eu peur du maire de fréjus fut maire de
toulon et du maire de nice qui sont
venus le voir en lui disant hubert falco
crécy patronat en disant attention si tu
veux quand soutiennent tu vas faire
embrassons nous folleville schéma kron
ensuite comme cette menace était
géographiquement plus éloigné parce
qu'il avait fini après avoir dit qu'il
n'irait pas qu'il était un homme libre
qui faisait les choses bref il va et
monsieur jacob qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
qui est c'est pas einstein quand même eu
monsieur jacob et ses camarades font les
gros yeux on ne sait pas très bien ce
qu'ils se sont dit mais enfin on sait ce
qu'il en est sorti et à la fin parce
qu'il ya quelques s'infiltrer
figaro matin midi et soir je l'aurais
scénario morgue et une cage des siens
chaque doute et se dotera que ça me
divers artistes avant de m'endormir
mais dans cette affaire crème le comment
dire le renouvellement du comportement
politique ne me semble pas à l'ordre du
jour sur sur sa sur la en gros on a
l'impression que c'est il s'est échappé
belle mais surtout la fin pour la survie
des leurs est sûre sur le positionnement
que peut avoir l air par rapport quand
même à la double pression malgré logan
dans l'autre tout dépend tout dépend du
résultat de la présidentielle si macron
réélu évidemment la grotte éclate parce
que là il ya ce qui rompt et qu'ils
seront nombreux passer gmac moses malone
a déjà attendu cinq ans on va pas encore
attendre cinq ans donc là il y aura une
grosse partie de la droite qui rachète
macron l'autre partie de la droite se
dire il faut qu'on montre quelque chose
alors ce rapt europe avec marine le pen
mais avec marion maréchal avec des pays
et puis on essaiera de faire un truc
comme ça si bas qu'on gagne en revanche
il m'a compères la droite repartira
comme un seul homme derrière le
président de droite comme ça s'est
toujours fait pas ce qu'on nous dit la
droite divisée mais on l'a toujours moi
j'ai toujours connu le rpr et l'udf
pasqua séguin chirac balladur chirac
jusqu'à l'a toujours été divisés
il ya toujours des familles dont il ya
eu les orléanistes l'ailé l'église
ils se sont toujours taper dessus puis
puis après quand ça gagne on s'entend
quand ça perd on se dispute c'est
toujours comme ça c'est la vie
donc s'il gagne ça marchera sir paire
d'as pour la wii la droite éclatera et
le nouveau parti de droite finalement il
y aura un parti dès qu un grand parti
d'opposition d'extrême droite ont faim
de droite extrême autour de marine le
pen et d'une partie des républicains est
un grand parti de centre-droit au
pouvoir autour de macron ce qui est
intéressant c'est le soir c'est la
disparition de la gauche du paysage dire
que on est en train de le canton se
projette dans l'avenir
la bataille de la présidentielle c'est
entre leur assemblée nationale les
républicains les maquereaux nice tu
blagues ou des petits dés et quand on
pense à l'avenir on se dit est ce que je
commence à vasco concret composer entre
la droite leur assemblée nationale les
maquereaux d'ist la gauche qui
historiquement faisait une bonne moitié
de de lectorat dans ce pays aujourd'hui
c'est pas qu'elle a disparu
elle est passée de 50 à 40 aujourd'hui
en gros elle fait 36 et 30 arrivée à
s'unir il arriverait à exister et
peut-être on peut être présent premier
tour une people
mais comme mais en plus ils sont divisés
mais 30 c'est pas 50 à dire qu'il ya une
espèce défendre un déplacement du centre
de gravité de ce pays vers la droite
tient pas il ya trois partis de droite
aujourd'hui 20 centre-droit la droite et
l'extrême droite et le fond d'apple
montrent que c'est d'ailleurs un
phénomène européen
d'ailleurs je pense que ça va être très
intéressant ces sélections régionales a
si peu de temps des élections
présidentielles sera pas intéressant
pour les régions ça il faut que les
régions perdent l'idée quand on va
s'intéresser à elle et à leur sort mais
ça va être intéressant pour les
politiques nationales parce que si
bertrand est élue si mariani est élu si
les verts font un bon score si la gauche
se répondent plusieurs morceaux façon
puzzle comme dirait l'autre
aidé en cela par monsieur mélenchon qui
dans ne cesse d'affirmer ça ça après
portant sur autre chose son discours de
lille et c'était absolument super moi je
dis depuis longtemps que c'est un
personnage de labiche et ben vraiment là
tout y est le langage l'enflure du
langage la verve verts/be g ration enfin
tout y est mais en tout cas pour le plan
politique
ils aident puissamment à la division de
la gauche et je pense que c'est
il va il va réussir donc mais là
vraiment si c'est trois événements se
passe parce que on a eu la surprise de
voir que monsieur julien bayou en dépit
ou peut être grâce aux étranges propos
qu'il a tenus propos fâcheux il faut
bien dire un peu pitoyable non non pas
tant que la fiche qui la soutenaient
marley dans les affiches des campagnes
d'affichage attaque les boumeurs on a eu
un calque etc
soit elle est vraiment les pitoyables
mais ce qui est encore plus pitoyable
c'est que lui aussi avec un courage des
coûts tant que encourager la fuit il
après avoir diffusé lui même cette
affiche il a dit je ne l'avais pas le
débat de la semaine je l'avais la vache
est désolé mais il n'avait pas validé
n'empêche que pour ça il l'a fait et ça
a eu pour résultat 2
lui accorder conférer une notoriété qui
n'avaient pas et du coup ils dépassent
dans une île de france
la candidate socialiste madame pulvar
donc si ce mouvement là des écologistes
là aussi sans feu et ce travail comme la
grenouille de la fable on va assister à
des choses intéressantes après ces
régions on va voir pour les régionales
macron qu'aujourd'hui nous court après
la droite joue la droite se disent je
gagne la présidentielle vont chercher
les électeurs de droite se rendant
compte que si comme c est philippe le
ray xavier bertrand était lui aussi
pécresse et telus il faut quitter viser
un rouleau la balle à droite en train de
se ressouder
vas-tu te retourner vers la gauche d'en
bas là il ya plein de petites gens à
récupérer ils sont tous divisés et va
refaire un maquereau de gauche qui veut
dire revenez à moi les électeurs de
gauche et pour repartir en bataille
c'est très intéressant mais le problème
de cette position centrale c'est qu'il
ya un moment où les un autre quotidien
mayfield heroes un jour que les deux
droites over autre clé de gauche et un
moment les uns les autres et ce par se
rendre compte ce qui ce qui dit au camp
d'en face
il fait danseuse vous diront qu'à faire
le grand écart on se claque la cuisse
alors le rassemblement national en sort
gagnant en tous les cas selon alex même
si la liste et les rem s'est sabordé que
renaud muselier fait mine de revenir
dans la ligne l air le mal est fait
emmanuel macron continue avec brio sur
l'entreprise de déconstruction de
l'échiquier politique entamée en 2017
après 2000 ps les républicains estiment
ghiwane et cet autre internaute qui dit
les républicains devraient instaurer une
nouvelle liste n'est pas normal que les
électeurs de droite votent pour élire au
m pour l'instant bien les républicains
ont leur liste et il est question plutôt
que ce soit lrm maintenant qui est sa
propre liste dont on papa en paca le
retour de babineau que l'on salue à ce
que ça faisait longtemps qu'on ne vous
avait pas vus il y a une fracture au
sein des républicains entre la une macro
compatible aline de jacob et ciotti
emmanuel macron se frotte les mains et
nicole
prédit que tout ce qui va arriver c'est
la victoire du r'n et dernière peut-être
question pourquoi monsieur castex est il
obligé nous demande cet internaute a
annoncé une décision que monsieur
muselier n'avait pas encore pris
s'appelle un piège en politique grâce à
ses formidables parce que là tout le
monde va dire comme toute cette affaire
de radoub foiré lamentablement
tout le monde va dire c'est de la faute
de castaic quelle maladresse
il a dit ça ce n'était pas le bon moment
ce n'était pas les bons mots c'était pas
le bon jour c'était pas ceux ci mais la
vérité c'est ce que prouve que c'est
qu'il n'y est absolument pour rien c'est
une affaire qui était monté à l'elysée
de toutes pièces avec thierry solère
emmanuel macron et castaner qu'on a dit
à castex en animant tiens voilà ce que
tu vas dire il a dit ça au jdd
et il va porter le chapeau du d'un
ratage mais il n'est pour rien saison
c'est pas lui qui négocie avec muselier
c'est pas lui le solaire n'est pas du
tout un de ces hommes c'est un homme de
macron est innée mais c'est très amusant
de voir comment ce malgré une fois de
plus de castex fois de plus porter le
chapeau
je suis absolument d'accord j'imagine le
moment président de la république on
voit que le problème existe elle lui dit
monsieur le premier je n'avais pas
oublier que vous étiez le chef de la
majorité
atika c'est ben là autre chose et hop
c'est parti pour cette histoire négocié
par solaire en effet je vous propose de
parler d'un autre sujet qui est agitée
qui va agiter également ses les
commémorations autour
il vient du 200e anniversaire de la mort
de napoléon
j'emploie tous ces mots à dessein parce
que tous les mots sont pesées
semble-t-il ces dernières heures au
trébuchet commémorer n'est pas célébrée
c'est l'élément de langage à l'elysée
alors demain emmanuel macron présidera
les cérémonies marquant donc le 200e
anniversaire de la mort de napoléon à
sainte-hélène l'événement d'ailleurs
sera à suivre en direct sur figaro live
avec pierre banda qui est historien la
fondation napoléon et charlotte barillon
dennebouy on pourra entendre un exposé
de jean tulard et ça se terminera avec
un dépôt de gerbe devant le tombeau de
l'empereur aux invalides le président de
la république va prendre la parole
promis dit l'elysée il ne se dérobera
pas alors pour l'heure voici ce qu'en
pense
marine le pen elle était l'invité ce
matin de rtl
pure pourquoi ne pas célébrer napoléon
c'est un des très grands personnages
historiques je regrette que le président
de la république le commémore à la va
vite
je pense que le but zambien aurait
évidemment mérité des commémorations
plus importante
de son côté le commissaire à
l'exposition napoléon à une autre
analyse et notamment sur la prise de
parole que va faire le président la
question que je me pose mais à mon avis
est ce que c'est ce qui déterminera tout
le sens de son discours c'est comment
est-ce qu'il va inclure napoléon dans le
récit de l'histoire de france qui veut
donner quoi comme c'est le président de
la république évidemment ça va donner un
ton pour ça mais peut-être plus
important encore moi ce que je
retiendrai de cette intervention des
maliennes macron c'est que pour la
première fois depuis longtemps un
président de la république veut se
saisir d'un sujet d'ordre culturel on va
dire ça comme ça
c'est à dire qu'il veut se saisir de
l'histoire de france
ces célèbres à la va-vite film est nommé
on rate complètement cette histoire là
aussi il ya une lâcheté formule avec une
ration la célébration etc
enfin on avait déjà eu ça d'ailleurs je
ne sais plus quelle occasion jeu plus
c'était pas un moment de l'anniversaire
de céline ou avec le courage aussi la
bactérie décoration parce que la
célébration même du dictionnaire des
commémorations de l'agenda des
commémorations de la chaîne mais c'était
une occasion formidable cette 200e
anniversaire qu'il aurait fallu préparer
de longue main je reconnais que vides ne
facilitait pas les choses mais quand
même
après tout on peut toujours s'y prendre
mais même maintenant sur cette période
qui va de la révolution à la fin de l'
empire qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comment est-ce qu'on passe de ces trois
âges de la révolution au consulat du
consulat un empire qu'est-ce qui fait et
à des thèses extrêmement différentes là
dessus mais très intéressante qui ne
sont pas des thèses de secteurs qui sont
des thèses de gens qui ont travaillé
l'histoire et qui ont une analyse qui
diverge de celle d'autres gens qui ont
comme eux travaillent et l'histoire
qu'est ce qui fait que napoléon a fait
la guerre
attendez on sait pardon c'était un
sanguinaire c'était un sanguinaire il
finit le jeu pas pourquoi il n'est pas
sûr nitoo d'ailleurs il devrait y être
titre rétrospective c'était un match
chaud c'était un sanguinaire c'était un
esclavagiste c'était une brute était
inculpé des temps bon très bien mais le
la compréhension de l'histoire qui est
une chose qui manque tellement moi ça
m'avait beaucoup frappé d'ailleurs c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
quitté sciences po sans tambour ni
trompette mais c'était sous richard
descoings l'affaiblissement de
l'enseignement de l'histoire qui se
traduisait pas par mille choses et qui
est une catastrophe
enfin on voit bien que la nécessité de
comprendre que le présent sort du passé
est une chose qui ne peut que guider
l'action de ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
ça c'était intéressant je ne dis pas que
destin napoléon soit pas intéressant il
est passionnant parce qu'il est
tellement hors du commun que tout le
monde a envie de comprendre mais il y
avait autre chose à faire sur l'histoire
elle-même sur les événements et pour le
reste s'il faut condamner la bonne heure
allons-y condamnant napoléon mais alors
qui va échapper à la condamner
sur toussaint louverture il avait aboli
l esclavage mais il avait maintenu la
traite
billaud varenne ce sanguinaire billaud
varenne qui était le plus féroce contre
ce qu'on appelait les indulgents au
moment de la révolution qui a été
condamné à la déportation
parce qu'ils s'étaient opposés à
robespierre non pas sur la terreur mais
sur la sur la place que robespierre
prenez lui même à l'intérieur du système
de gouvernement il a été déporté la
guyane et à peine l'esclavagé at il été
rétablie raconte alejo carpentier dans
le siècle des lumières qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il a acheté des esclaves il en a
vendu un homme de gauche
bon on va dire que j'aimerais bien
savoir qui a une petite chance
d'échapper à la condamnation le
déboulonnage de ce statut et c est tout
ça on a l'impression que derrière les
réseaux sociaux dans les réseaux sociaux
faute d'avoir eux mêmes une prise sur la
réalité d'aujourd'hui
il y a des gens qui n'ont qu'une idée
c'est de flinguer ce qui a pu se faire
sans sang en sang qui sont en exposer
les raisons mais simplement en réduisant
tout à un minimum de choses condamnables
le bail ou encore ça nous dire on l'a vu
avec la prise de position d'elisabeth
moreno qui avait dit napoléon était
sexiste
on sent tout de même un malaise au sein
du gouvernement sur la célébration de
napoléon alex il faut commémorer célébré
comme une crétinisation de discours
publics et effrayante sur ces questions
c'est vrai que naples on peut être un
objet de controverse quand toi skieurs
ne vont pas exactement dans le sens
auquel on pense aujourd'hui
historiquement il ya toute une école de
gauche nicole marxiste qui défend des
napoléon qui était le libérateur qui a
porté les idéaux de libération dans le
monde entier et c'était plutôt
d'ailleurs la droite c'était ben ville
qui disait monsieur d'histoire dans pire
c'est complètement idiot c'est pas dans
le génie national
il a rendu là il a remis la clé c'est la
pub france plus petit qu il que ce qu'il
avait trouvé en entrant vab ont donc
toutes ces questions là ce sont des
questions tout à fait intéressante qui
se ça mérite absolument d'être débattue
mais alors se dire ah oui il était
gentil il était méchant et tout ça c'est
une petite c'est vraiment de l'idiotie
mémé généralisée et donc ce que je
crains alors bon déjà on peut dire
comment - comment dire macron
va faire quelque chose parce que moi je
me suis un homme de l'époque où
dominique de villepin grand napoléonien
devant l'éternel jeu le compteur des 100
jours et de la geste napoléonienne n'a
même pas voulu célébrer ont commémoré au
service parce que c'était mal vu il
fallait pas le faire donc au moins on
peut dire que mcgraw hill y va bon
maintenant on va voir ce qu'il va dire
et alors je là j'ai quand même quelques
éléments de langage qu'on nous délivre à
la main je pense que ça va être
intéressant à décrypter
parce que donc ça ne sera pas une
hagiographie béate ce serait hors de
question non non non non ce ne sera pas
un déni vaincre l non mais ça ne sera
pas non plus une repentance et une
lecture anachronique et donc et je pense
qu'on va avoir un numéro dans même temps
de ni l'un ni l'autre de peut-être ben
qu'oui peut-être banques nos qui va être
absolument sublime et on dira alors oui
le code civil oui mais en même temps le
quotidien ce n'est quand même pas assez
féministe la grandeur et la gloire oui
même temps il a tué des gens c'est quand
même pas bien de tuer des gens enfin bon
on va voir ce que va dire un maquereau
on le sait pas encore mais je crains que
ça nous va y à un numéro d'équilibriste
de grands écarts dans la droite ligne de
celui de monsieur muselier dans 10 des
sujets moins nobles je suis souris
vivent les rats je pense que j'ai résumé
la médiation du président
un 3g une source qui nous dit le
président va déconstruire la figure
napoléon dia ba ça y est déconstruite
nous avons alors non mais attendez car
ajoute-t-on de même source
déconstruire ces rebâtir et transmettre
tôt plus on déconstruit plus en pâtit il
fallait y penser
oui ça te dire que se construira l'enjeu
je prépare un moratoire il faut dire
qu'avec pendant un an
il est des mots comme dépoussiérer
résister déconstruire reconstruire et
c'est qu'on s'engage à ne pas utiliser
avec derrida comme impartiale
il suffit d'aller aux états unis pour à
quel point c'est considérable est
beaucoup plus aux états unis dès lors il
est temps qu'en france
est-ce que pas aller si dénoncer la
crétinisation du discours public sur ces
questions historiques
est ce que cette christianisation savait
pas également une espèce de moralisation
de et de l'histoire une moralisation la
moralisation c'est facile ça demande pas
de regarder les dossiers ça devant pas
d'étudier l'effet sa demande pas
d'exercer son jugement sa demande de
prendre son opinion pour un jugement à
condition d'ailleurs qu'on ait son de
pignons en réalité son opinion c'est
celle des autres et c'est en général
celles des réseaux sociaux
donc effectivement c'est beaucoup plus
facile on appelle sa moralisation
ce su pas tout à fait sûr que la morale
prince de ligne orageuse à voir avec ces
du moraliste pc c'est une
c'est une forme d'impuissance mois ya
une chose qui me frappe dans cette
violence des réseaux sociaux
j'ai commencé ma vie professionnelle à
travailler en psychiatrie et j'avais été
frappé de plusieurs choses notamment
d'une et que les hommes qui battent
leurs femmes dans l'immense majorité des
d'ailleurs les femmes qui battent leurs
hommes parce qu'il ya aussi mot face
elles sont moins nombreuses sont dans la
majorité des impuissants et que c'est
l'impuissance qui les rend violent
voilà je dirais que c'est la même je
voulais quelque chose de la même nature
il ya une impuissance à agir sur le
monde dans lequel on est qui se
transforme en une recherche de coupables
en une série d'expressions de plus en
plus violentes et en une flopée quant à
lyon mais malheureusement c'est un
phénomène qui n'affecte pas
exclusivement ni même principalement les
réseaux sociaux des réseaux sur le
déversoir de 12 ans mais c'est l'école
c'est l'université c'est la politique
c'est des associations
virapin apou l esclavage c'est mal oui
on le sait que l'esclavagisme alors
maintenant après ça c'est effectivement
c'est vite dit après la question c'est
pourquoi est ce que c'est un homme à
naples on se dit qu'il va rétablir
l'esclavagé
ça c'est intéressant c'est pas parce
qu'il pour l'esclavagé c'est qu'il ya
les anglais il faut pas c'est plutôt
dans un souci d'apaisement avec les
anglais alors on peut dire que c'est une
mauvaise décision que sap a tellement
marché mais là encore c'est intéressant
mais juste dire l'esclavagé c'est mal et
faire la guerre c'est mal oui bien sûr
mais ça parce que c'est de la politique
la politique c'est franchement c'est pas
joli ça ne m'est jamais la politique
c'est des compromis et des
compromissions et c'est comme ça et ça
passe par un certain nombre de choses de
gens il y en a plein si si les gens
veulent avoir une idée de ce que sait il
pas il suffit d'aller voir une pièce de
shakespeare enfin et des pièces
politique a ses racines viennent aussi
de considérer que tout cela verture
après avoir aboli l'esclavagé avait
établi la peine de mort pour les sdf
esclaves qui avait dans l'idée de
quitter nina parce que c'était quand
même ça alors on a appris quand même pas
mal de choses sur toussaint louverture
ce soir est effectivement je me dis que
c'est une des choses et originalité
période sur comme évidemment un napoléon
après l'avoir fait général quand même
pas oublier que j'ai deroff lapalu en
fait la carrière de toussaint louverture
et après en effet l'a fait venir en
france et là l'a emprisonné mais il faut
pas non plus en faire un saint de
vitrail
voilà vous êtes de napoléon non plus
c'est pas la question bien sûr mais on
veut que que qu' on peut on peut
s'interroger sur le l'héritage et
l'héritage militaire et stratégique de
napoléon chercher des centres-villes maï
dans la politique vraiment être idiot
et bien justement pour aller quand même
voir ce qu'on peut dire également sur
napoléon un peu plus connaître
napoléon deux conseils d'abord
demain les cérémonies seront commentés
donc par un historien de la fondation
napoléon que c'est pire brindas et qui
sera avec vous et avec nous si dans le
studio de stream de figaro live avec
charlotte barillon de nos billes et et
en attendant indispensable à lire à se
procurer le dernier numéro du figaro
hors série sur napoléon l'épopée le
mythe le procès avec les meilleurs
spécialistes des meilleurs historiens de
napoléon 1er étaient un jour invité à
faire une conférence ajaccio à l'époque
où le prince napoléon par l'actuel mais
son père était maire adjoint à la
culture
et il n'avait pas pu venir à la
conférence mais il m'avait dit qu'il
souhaitait inviter à dîner après et donc
que je vois en effet un très grand type
il est immense qui arrive dans la salle
alors que les gens étaient en train de
s'égailler qui arrivait à moi et moi
comme j'ai appris le protocole je dis
bonjour mon seigneur ils me répondront
vous savez moi je suis plutôt psu
sexuelle prince napoléon et dans le
numéro du figaro hors série
juste je donne les commentaires des
internautes napoléon bonaparte et à
grands hommes se lient mart se limiter à
certains faits et réducteur estime
nicole élan on ne marchande pas la
grandeur de la france denise napoléon
fait partie de notre histoire stop à la
can cette culture et antoine napoléon
c'est la france ne pas célébrer napoléon
ce n'est pas célébré la france on sait
que sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya une forte communauté napoléon
peut-être que c'en est l'illustration ce
soit sinon sur nous sur nos réseaux et
également à l'étranger
on vous posait la question sur twitter
l'héritage historique laissé par
napoléon doit-il être célébrés et vous
dit oui à 79% vous avez été relativement
nombreux à répondre à la question merci
beaucoup et on se retrouve demain donc
pour le live napoléon également pour
point de vue avec guillaume roquette
chloé morin et gabriel cluzel a très
vite supplie en live